amigos os hago una pregunta os habéis
parado alguna vez a pensar cuánto gasta
de verdad cuánto le cuesta realmente a
los eeuu su ejército y todas las
operaciones militares que lleva a cabo
día tras día a lo largo y ancho del
mundo
pues bien eso es precisamente a lo que
vamos a tratar de responder en este
vídeo y ojo amigos porque este no es un
debate cualquiera la industria militar
es una de las industrias más opacas más
influyentes y más poderosas de los eeuu
bueno de los eeuu y prácticamente de
todo el mundo así que amigos contestar a
la pregunta que os he realizado supone
ni más ni menos que abrir un debate y
cuyas implicaciones no son precisamente
pequeñas la factura puede ser de cientos
de miles de millones de dólares pero
bien hecha esta advertencia ahora ya sí
veamos qué está ocurriendo en los
pasillos tanto del pentágono como del
capitolio
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hablar del ejército de eeuu supone tener
en cuenta cifras desorbitadas y también
una inmensa maquinaria burocrática y
política tan grande y tan opaca que
prácticamente podemos hablar de un
gobierno paralelo fijaos un informe del
propio pentágono en 2015 cifró en
decenas de miles de millones repito
decenas de miles de millones de dólares
cada año el sobrecoste causado por malas
prácticas en la gestión de las fuerzas
armadas
malas prácticas como por ejemplo pagar a
contratistas privados más dinero del que
cabe esperar en un mercado competitivo
vamos a estar en peligro porque estamos
gastando dólares como si no importara
robert stein director de cardwell
capital management y ex presidente de la
junta de negocios de defensa y ojo no
penséis sólo en las grandes empresas de
la industria militar esas que se
encargan de producir los cazas los
misiles y demás equipos militares para
nada una buena parte de todos estos
miles de millones que cada año se
evaporan proceden de actividades como la
contabilidad la logística o los recursos
humanos tal cual como lo escucháis
[Música]
de hecho la burocracia de las fuerzas
armadas de eeuu es tan grande que emplea
ni más ni menos que algo más de un
millón de personas un millón de personas
para cosas como contabilidad o recursos
humanos atentos a este gráfico del
'washington post'
[Música]
como veis el ejército de eeuu tiene
prácticamente tantas personas en los
despachos en actividades administrativas
como preparándose para la guerra o
realizando tareas de seguridad o
entrenamiento y todo esto claro tiene un
coste casi una cuarta parte del
presupuesto militar se invierte en este
tipo de tareas que bueno digamos que son
importantes pero una cuarta parte
en otras palabras toda esta burocracia
por sí misma supondría atentos el tercer
mayor presupuesto militar del mundo y no
estaría lejos de la segunda plaza de
china
y eso no es todo según un estudio del
mismísimo departamento de defensa
publicado en octubre de 2017
aproximadamente una de cada cinco
instalaciones que tiene el pentágono no
vale para nada está ociosa podrían
cerrarlas sin ninguna consecuencia
militar y ahorrarse muchos millones de
dólares pero digamos que los políticos
de washington no están muy por la labor
por cierto la descripción de este vídeo
os dejo el enlace a varios de estos
informes como veis amigos todo lo que
tiene que ver con el pentágono y el
departamento de defensa de eeuu supone
hablar de estructuras hiperburocracia
sele fantásticas y muy muy costosas pues
bien como luego veremos en este mismo
vídeo todo este derroche tiene una gran
importancia en el debate político pero
ahora ya sí veamos cuánto dinero le
suponen realmente a los eeuu sus
aventuras militares
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el coste de las guerras
a decir verdad las aventuras militares
de eeuu no son algo nada extraño si
contamos la guerra fría eeuu ha estado
virtualmente en guerra prácticamente
todos los años desde atentos 1941
y además lo conocemos todos desde
finales del año 2001 y el ejército
norteamericano ha estado activamente en
combate todos los años y sabéis que no
parece que las cosas vayan a cambiar en
un futuro próximo sería las operaciones
en el índico en áfrica en yemen en el
pacífico en europa del este y sobre todo
por supuesto las guerras de irak y
afganistán os hacéis una idea de cuánto
han costado todos estos conflictos pues
atentos porque la cifra es de escándalo
pero antes un apunte una cosa amigos es
el presupuesto anual de defensa y otra
el presupuesto de operaciones es decir
cuando escuchamos a hablar de cuánto
gasta eeuu en su ejército no se suele
tener en cuenta el coste propio de las
guerras y las operaciones militares pues
bien el caso es que desde 2001 los
contribuyentes estadounidenses se han
gastado tan solo en estas aventuras
militares la friolera de 1,7 millones de
dólares
17 billones tanto como el tamaño
combinado la suma del pib anual de las
economías de colombia perú argentina
chile ecuador uruguay panamá bolivia
paraguay y guatemala que se dice pronto
visto de otra forma en dólares de hoy es
más del doble de lo que costó la guerra
de vietnam o cinco veces el coste de la
guerra de corea
pero ojo porque si pensáis que esta
cifra es elevada esperar porque aún no
hemos terminado el gasto de las guerras
de irak y afganistán por ejemplo aún no
ha terminado y no me refiero sólo al
gasto militar que quedan por delante
sino también a los costes que ya se han
producido pero que el gobierno federal
tendrá que pagar en el futuro
y costes como la atención médica a largo
plazo para excombatientes por lesiones
producidas en combate gastos
comprometidos para veteranos los costes
de la deuda con la que se ha financiado
la guerra la sustitución de equipos
etcétera etcétera en total las
estimaciones hablan de que tan sólo
estas dos guerras terminarán costando
entre 4 y 6 billones de dólares
menuda cantidad de dinero para que nos
podamos hacer una idea de su dimensión
real podemos decir que equivale a todo
el gasto militar de los países europeos
de la otan durante los próximos 15 o 23
años que se dice pronto vamos que todas
estas aventuras militares son una
auténtica ruina pero sabéis que creo que
es muy importante fijarse en la factura
para ser más prudentes en el futuro
[Música]
por ejemplo cuando uno visita a eeuu una
cosa que llama la atención es el mal
estado en que están las infraestructuras
carreteras metros ferrocarriles etcétera
etcétera
de hecho el tema de las infraestructuras
empieza a ser un problema
kristen wiig entre lienz dels horts air
berlin o cualquier peligro
huawei con el apoyo nalón es igualmente
del swift
[Música]
tan solo con lo que han costado las
guerras de irak y afganistán los eeuu
podrían tener las mejores
infraestructuras del mundo
[Música]
las tres ferias de américa bertin words
spinning putin poner tu tenedores muerte
despertar de mano con el dinero de
infestación guardia del mar y esperan al
mediodía enero web autoridades text
llevar a tener en esta idea de que la
gente no sólo es no deja de cantar east
steve jobs rodríguez edición extra
bien hasta aquí creo que la cosa está
clara hemos visto cuánto le cuestan a
los estadounidenses las aventuras
militares de washington por el mundo
ahora me parece interesante que echemos
un vistazo a cuánto gasta realmente en
defensa al gobierno federal y ya os
adelanto que puede que os llevéis alguna
sorpresa
[Música]
me llaman a buscar cuídame decir william
and valentines page
[Música]
el verdadero gasto militar
más o menos creo que todos lo sabemos el
presupuesto de defensa de eeuu es con
diferencia el más grande del mundo
fijaos para 2017 por ejemplo es de unos
560 mil millones de dólares a lo que hay
que sumar como hemos visto hace un
momento unos 60 mil millones más para
gastos de operaciones
y esto viene a suponer aproximadamente
tres veces el gasto militar de china o
nueve veces el gasto militar de rusia
sin embargo estas cantidades no recogen
todos los gastos que el mundo militar le
genera al gobierno de eeuu pensemos por
ejemplo en el coste de los tratamientos
médicos de los heridos en combate o el
gasto que supondrán las partidas para
veteranos echad un vistazo a este
gráfico
[Música]
si como veis si tenemos en cuenta todas
estas partidas el gasto de las fuerzas
armadas crece hasta más de 900 mil
millones de dólares al año 900 mil
millones de dólares y aún nos quedaría
aparte gastos de seguridad nacional como
muchas partidas del gobierno que
financian a agencias de inteligencia
como la cia pero es que incluso si
tomamos exclusivamente el presupuesto
del departamento de defensa y las armas
nucleares es decir 620 mil millones de
dólares vemos como el esfuerzo militar
en términos de pib es uno de los mayores
del mundo miremos por donde lo miremos
las cifras en juego son desorbitadas sin
embargo antes de dar la cuestión por
finiquitada espera un momento porque el
dominio militar de eeuu resulta algo
menos impresionante cuando tenemos en
cuenta algunos factores
[Música]
primero la diferencia de precios es
decir no se pueden comprar las mismas
cosas con un dólar en eeuu que con un
dólar en china por ejemplo si corregimos
esta cuestión vemos como el gasto
militar de eeuu vendría a equivaler a la
suma del gasto militar de china y de
rusia sigue siendo mucho pero ya no es
tan impresionante y segundo muy
importante cuando tenemos en cuenta la
evolución de los últimos años
[Música]
me explico en dólares constantes esto es
corrigiendo los efectos de la inflación
el gasto en defensa real ha caído desde
2010 un 25 por ciento la reducción más
grande en décadas y en cierto modo esto
es lo que preocupa a muchos analistas y
políticos de washington especialmente
del partido republicano
nation
in one
en que puede ser que a pesar de todo el
dinero que eeuu gastado y en defensa no
sea suficiente veámoslo
[Música]
un poder menguante
desde la caída de la unión soviética
y el consecuente final de la guerra fría
como parece sensato el tamaño de las
fuerzas armadas de eeuu se ha reducido
sustancialmente
hablamos de menos submarinos menos
portaaviones menos bombarderos menos
soldados
etcétera etcétera
a cambio también han llegado nuevos
equipos como los f-22 raptors
los bombarderos b-2 los recientes efe 35
una nueva clase de portaaviones nuevos
cruceros o también entre otras cosas
drones y misiles de alta precisión si
así es y toda esta renovación
tecnológica tiene dos consecuencias por
un lado ha incrementado las capacidades
militares de eeuu pero por otro lado
también los costes de los equipos y las
operaciones y claro como hemos visto el
presupuesto lleva años hacia abajo años
de su financiación nos han dado una
fuerza debilitada que a pesar del arduo
trabajo de nuestras valientes tropas
está mal equipada para manejar las
misiones que seguimos lanzando edwin
feulner fundador y presidente de la
fundación here it is por todo esto en el
partido republicano y también hay que
decirlo en gran parte del partido
demócrata parecen tener las cosas muy
claras hay que incrementar el
presupuesto militar
[Música]
d
por ejemplo el ex candidato a la
presidencia y famoso senador por arizona
john mccain que por cierto es el
presidente del comité de servicios
armados del senado es uno de los
políticos que más empeño tienen en esta
cuestión y ha propuesto llevar el
presupuesto militar hasta los 800.000
millones de dólares dicen que la actual
financiación es escasa y que ha causado
por ejemplo los accidentes que la
journée vilamarina ha tenido en el
pacifico relevan al comandante de la
séptima flota tras varios accidentes con
buques de eeuu en el pacífico y también
que las nuevas amenazas como corea del
norte o una china cada vez más fuerte
algo que ya hemos visto en visual
político obligan a renovar toda la
infraestructura estratégica
y eso no es algo barato tan solo rehacer
y modernizar el arsenal nuclear esto es
las armas nucleares
los bombarderos los misiles y los
submarinos como ha prometido trump
supone una inversión en los próximos 30
años de más de 12 billones de dólares
sin embargo amigos si gastas más que
nadie mucho más y aún así no llegas no
será que tienes que replantearte tu
campo de acción no debería tal vez eeuu
modificar de alguna manera su rol para
no verse involucrado en conflictos y
crisis continuamente en cualquier lugar
del mundo llevar el gasto militar mucho
más allá es una cuestión de seguridad
nacional o de interés de la gran
industria armamentística que de una u
otra forma financia generosamente todo
tipo de lobbies y campañas políticas
estas son las preguntas las respuestas
quedan abiertas pero ahora torno para ti
crees que eeuu debe incrementar su gasto
militar déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
no te olvides darle la xxi está
resultado interesante el vídeo y por
supuesto amigos si aún no sabéis
suscrito a visual político no perdáis
más tiempo porque tenemos muchas
sorpresas por delante
un saludo y hasta la próxima
dyn
[Música]